it was January 2022 as fewer properties
were being listed and market conditions
were tightening in the GTA this is when
police say Toronto homeowners away on a
business trip discovered their home was
sold without their consent or knowledge
Toronto police are now looking for these
two people they allege pretended to be
the homeowners hired a real estate agent
and listed the Etobicoke property for
sale the home sold to new owners who
took possession investigators say the
legitimate owners never found out their
property had been sold until several
months later so how can something like
this happen this real estate expert says
it may be more common than one might
think somewhere along the way a person
with access to the land or registry
system whether it's a lawyer or another
person transferred the title from the
present homeowners to someone else
illegally that land registry system
Ronald fonso says is administered and
owned by taranet on behalf of the
Ontario government real estate lawyers
and others who are authorized to
transfer titles and sell houses have
access to it through specific key codes
their key code is
taken by somebody else or copied by
somebody else or misappropriated in some
way that person has access to the system
and can do whatever they want they can
transfer one house or a hundred houses
and Alfonso says thanks to coveted
precautions this type of fraud is
relatively easy to pull off pre-covet
clients need to go to a lawyer's office
when buying a home to sign documents
answer questions and present ID now you
can do what is called DocuSign or
electronic signing online you can easily
go into Photoshop
just copy a passport change a picture
here and there the lawyer is going to
accept them at face value in the
Etobicoke case police have not released
the names of the accused just these two
photos Global News reached out for more
information but police remaining
tight-lipped only directed all queries
back to the release as for how
homeowners and buyers can protect
themselves against this type of fraud
purchase title insurance
that protects the buyer against fraud
illegal transfer of title a whole range
of items Kayla McLean Global News